so I know a lot of you are crappy
photographers I mean flicker is proof of
that right and I am myself 12 when the
iphone doesn't really make it very easy
to take good photos and i got three
iphone apps here today i think would
make photography easier for you and also
just make things look a lot better the
three apps are camera bag tilt shift and
flick it camera bag and tilt shift our
editing applications and flick it is
just to upload faster to flickr so the
first application i'm going to show you
is called camera bag and it's got these
automatic filters you can fly to your
photos they just make really nice
effects just applied automatically so
such as this magazine effect that looks
really fancy and this instant polaroid
effect and this mono effect just makes
things black and white look around see
which one you actually like and then
click the Save button and then it's
right it's right in your library just
like that so pretty easy editing camera
bag costs two dollars in the app store
the second application i'm gonna show
you is called tilt shift and what it
does is it creates a focal point where
you can focus and blurs out everything
else around it kind of creating the
illusion of a depth of field effect what
you do is you just select a photo and
you can you can create a shape that
where you want to focus it on so i have
an oval shape loaded you can also select
this rectangular shape i think most
people are going to do the the circular
blur effects and then by sliding this
rule or you can adjust the blur around
it so you can make it very blurry or you
can just make the pedestal yeah very fun
application to use after you're done
applying the effect you can just hit
save and it saves that as a new picture
doesn't overwrite your original
tilt-shift is two dollars in the app
store and the third application i'm
going to show you is called flick its
and it's nothing magical or just get
your photos straight to flickr and i
think it's kind of a pain to get your
photos of flickr sometimes I don't want
to plug in my iphone you know to sync it
and then upload it from the computer
i'll just go automatically to the
internet so flick it is a free
application and i think it's even better
than the flick your application it's
just it's really simple interface where
you can just select multiple photos or a
single photo you can apply tags
if you want and then just name the
photos too if you want and just hit
upload and go straight to Flickr really
fast so those are three awesome
applications I think will make you a nun
crappy photographer all you got to do
spend four dollars